this video is made possible by nordvpn
we live our lives online more and more
these days particularly over the last
year
unfortunately that means that cybercrime
is also on the rise that's where nordvpn
comes in with nordvpn
all your internet data stays safe behind
a wall of next generation encryption
as we've seen in just the last year in
hong kong and myanmar political
situations can change rapidly
bringing censorship restrictions and
intrusive government controls
well nordvpn provides a kind of
invisibility blanket you can mask your
ip address
so that others can't see what you're
browsing online even better
nordvpn has servers all over the globe
meaning that you can enjoy
instant secure access to hundreds of
streaming websites worldwide
and one account lets you connect up to
six devices which means that you get to
watch visualpolitik content from
anywhere on the planet
and right now you can get a huge
discount on a two-year plan of nordvpn
at nordvpn.com
visualpolitik and when you use our code
visualpolitik you'll get an extra month
for free
it's risk-free with nord's 30-day
money-back guarantee so
take control of your internet experience
today with nordvpn
[Music]
humankind has already gone through the
copper age and the iron age
and right now at this very moment we're
in the middle of the lanthanide age
say what okay i'm sure that the vast
majority of you have never heard of
lanthanides in your life
however it is more than likely that here
and there you may have seen some news
about the so-called
rare earths we are talking about 17
chemical elements that are becoming
phenomenally important in the global
economy due to their use in a multitude
of devices to which we must add a highly
volatile catalyst china is currently the
world's largest producer of rare earth
elements
okay so far so good the problem or the
issue is that the asian giant is moving
to use the rare metals as a major
bargaining chip in its international
political strategy so the questions are
how can china take advantage of its
dominance of the global rare earth
elements market
and why are these mineral elements so
important and what alternative do
western bloc countries have to beijing's
moves
friends today at visualpolitik we're
going to answer these questions
but first let's take a look at a bit of
history
china's oil
perhaps the most surprising thing about
rare earth metals comes precisely from
their name because the truth is is that
some of these metals are as abundant as
nickel copper zinc
or even lead even the rarest are 200
times more commonly found
in nature than gold so rather than rare
earth elements
we could call them i don't know
reasonably abundant earth elements but
wait a minute because the problem is
that rare earth elements are found in
extremely low concentrations
even if we are talking about the richest
deposits these 17 valuable elements are
only found in concentrations of two
percent
at most
[Music]
and the fact is that rare earth elements
have become a vital input for the
manufacture of highly sophisticated
products
we're talking about all kinds of
electronic devices such as flat screen
monitors and smartphones their
importance is increasing even more with
efforts to reduce fossil fuel
consumption rare earth elements are used
in the permanent magnets that make up
for example the batteries of electric
cars or the drivers of wind turbines
neodymium and sumerian remember these
names they could be palmeira's new pair
of brazilian strikers but
in fact they are just two more
lanthanites however these metals are the
most sought after by the arms industry
their properties make them ideal for
precision guidance systems for missiles
and smart bombs as well as for use in
drones and aircraft so
no one should be surprised when we come
across news headlines like this
china targets rare earth export curbs to
hobble u.s defense industry financial
times you see as you all know the star
of the world military aviation market
is the f-35 from the u.s manufacturer
lockheed martin well each of these
aircraft uses no less than
kilos of rare earth material we are
talking about three percent of each
f-35s being rare earth elements
and many of you will be wondering but
how on earth is it possible that such
powerful american industries as
aeronautics and defense can be affected
by decisions made by the chinese
communist party itself
well look at this
[Music]
until the 1980s the united states was
the world's leading producer of most of
these 17 chemical elements the mountain
pass mine and processing plants in the
state of california was the world's
largest supplier of rare earth elements
for decades
extracting up to 20 000 tons of all per
day and in fact one of the lanthanides
obtained at mountain pass europium made
color television possible
but even so the exploitation of
lanthanides was not a particularly
attractive activity as i mentioned
before these minerals are found in very
low concentrations
even in the richest deposits that is to
say it is very difficult and expensive
to extract them on a large scale however
the chinese five-year plans bet heavily
on rare earth mining perhaps more as a
geostrategic than an economic strategy a
decision
that was made in the highest spheres and
just look at what the father of modern
china deng xiaoping said
there is oil in the middle east and
china has rare earths
deng xiaoping leader of china at the end
of the 20th century however
you should know that china's extraction
method played a very important role in
helping it to dominate the international
rare earth elements market
let me explain in addition to their low
concentration another of the most
characteristic features of rare earth
elements is that they are very difficult
to separate from the rock in which they
are found
the chemicals used to extract these
metals from the ore create toxic runoff
so dealing with these wastes some of
which become radioactive
significantly increases the economic
cost of these mining operations
and of course let's not kid ourselves
traditionally pollution was not
something that china was very much
concerned about
this made it much easier for china to
start large-scale production
and as this was happening the prices of
these metals plummeted
wiping out the profitability of mines in
other countries forcing them to close
chinese producers took advantage of
virtually non-existent environmental
regulations and low wages this is how
china took control of the global
rare earth's market by the end of the
20th century china had wiped out foreign
competition and cornered 97
of world production and that was when
the communist regime wanted to move on
to the second phase of the plan wait a
minute precisely what kind of plan are
we talking about
well listen up
[Music]
17 metals to rule them all
after gaining a privileged position
china came to play a role in rare earth
mining similar to that of
opec in oil beijing came to control a
kind of monopoly and a decade ago tried
to use rare earth elements for political
purposes in the dispute with japan
[Music]
as you all know japan has an important
electronics and automotive industry
which is precisely why it uses one-fifth
of the world's entire supply of rare
earth elements so
its economy faulted when china blocked
rare earth exports to the land of the
rising sun in 2010
after a diplomatic incident occurred
over the detention of a chinese fishing
vessel in japanese territorial waters
that beijing claims as its own japan
denounced china to the world trade
organization and the waters returned to
normal when the united states and the
european union supported the japanese
complaints but beijing's warning was
still very clear
all this however has not prevented china
from progressively reducing its exports
of rare earth elements year after year
and keep in mind it is not just that the
communist regime wanted to deliberately
harm the economies of rival powers it
was mainly a question of business
management first of all because rare
earth mining is expensive
so reducing the supply in a market where
demand is increasing all the time
well you can imagine the result supplies
squeezed
rare earth prices surge new york times
hold on a minute because
the most important thing is that china
is not a mere exporter of this raw
material the important key issue is that
it has become virtually the only country
that has developed the industry that
refines these metals and turns them into
materials ready for manufacturers
china controls about 80 of the world's
rare earth refining capacity and in fact
the united states has to send their
extracted minerals containing these
elements to china so the asian giants
realized what a huge business it had on
its hands and quickly changed its
strategy
[Music]
since 2015 china shut down a lot of
unlicensed minds granted to exploit rare
earth elements and focused its efforts
on importing these metals from other
countries
its overseas purchases of rare earth's
increased tenfold in just three years
by 2018 china had already become the
world's leading importer of rare earth
concentrate for example myanmar malaysia
and vietnam provide
25 of all rare earths processed by the
chinese industry
and you see as new technologies have led
to the boom in the demand for these
metals the rise in the price of
lanthanides has meant that rare earth
mining has become economically
profitable again
in other countries and because china did
not want to lose its control of the
market it moderated its presence as a
producer currently for example its
mining contributes 60
of the world's production of rare earth
elements in this way its rare earth
refining industry buys a large part of
this raw material from foreign countries
thus preventing them from becoming
suppliers to the west
and this kind of strategy is why china
continues to dominate the global rare
earth market
even if a whole trade war with the
united states has been unleashed along
the way however in case things get ugly
with washington again beijing has
already implemented its plan b
better safe than sorry china boosts rare
earth output
amid growing tech war with u.s asia
nikkei in this way beijing's goal is to
increase its domestic production of rare
earths by 30
this also fits in with the new
technological aspirations of this giant
which for example aims to ensure that by
2035 all
vehicle solds in the country will be
electric or hybrid a technological war
that the united states has to face with
such a scenario
and not only that we could show you
similar graphs from japan or the
european union and don't forget all this
is happening at precisely the same time
that the 17 chemical elements that
comprise the rare earths are
increasingly important for the
technology industry in developed
countries
so the question the big question we can
all ask ourselves is is there any
alternative to being at the mercy of the
wishes of the communist party of china
listen up
[Music]
the battle for rare earths
i don't think i need to remind you that
lately the relationship between beijing
and washington well
it's been going through a bit of a rough
patch we only have to take a look back
and remember the trade war all the
measures that the us government took
as recently as last september 2020
against companies such as huawei or smic
the semiconductor manufacturing
international corporation china's
largest chip manufacturer evidently
these moves did not amuse xi jinping's
regime which of course did not sit idly
by in december 2020 china passed a new
control law for strategic
materials whereby beijing can
arbitrarily limit the export of these
minerals you know the good old national
security excuse perhaps the oldest
political excuse in the world but hold
on a minute because that's not all
the latest thing that china is preparing
has set off alarm bells halfway around
the world
china tightens rare earth regulations
policing entire supply chain asia nikkei
with this new law the communist regime
intends nothing less than to have
everything related
to rare earth elements under its control
from extraction to export
including all industrial processing to
convert the minerals into refined metals
and then to transform these into
products ready for the manufacturer of
other goods whether they be
hard disks or tomahawk missiles okay
stop wait a minute
in theory it is complicated to think
that china would consider turning off
the tap mainly because doing so would
also hurt chinese companies which
typically make the motors and batteries
for u.s companies that use rare earth
magnets but of course when the
time comes if things go wrong the
question being asked in many western
foreign departments and
intelligence services is what on earth
could be done if the chinese
nevertheless decide to press the red
button and my friends at this point all
eyes turn to japan
a country that has been trying for a
decade to shake off its dependence of
the chinese communist party so the
question is what did japan do after that
diplomatic incident in 2010 well
basically it acted in three ways the
first was efficiency
thus the main objective of the japanese
manufacturers has been to reduce the
amount of rare earth elements needed to
achieve the same product in other words
smaller motors require less neodymium so
although japan now manufactures more
electric and hybrid vehicles than a
decade ago demand for this metal
including alloys has fallen by about 30
compared to 2008 levels
the second measure was to look for
alternative supplier countries vietnam
for example has significant reserves of
rare earths but lacks the necessary
investment to exploit them so that's
where the big japanese technology
corporations came into the picture
loaded with cash
so did the government which has even
financed foreign companies this is the
case for example of linus the australian
mining company with a rare earth
refinery in malaysia in this way japan
has managed to reduce its almost total
dependence on chinese imports to 58
and finally it has put in place a tool
that is as basic as it is effective in
tokyo they asked themselves if we
already do it with rice and gasoline why
not do it with warehouse and as we say
at visualpolitik no sooner said than
done
japan to stockpile rare metals as part
of effort to reduce dependence on china
japan forward
and this is the playbook japan has
passed on to washington and the rest of
the world on how to deal with china to
prevent beijing from being able to
punish the western tech industry
for the time being the united states has
resumed operation of the large mountain
pass mine which was closed in 2002 due
to increasingly stringent environmental
requirements in california and because
it could not compete with chinese
operations in addition democrats and
republicans have agreed that they should
push for a stateside
rare earth refining industry so that all
of the processing that these metals
undergo is done
on u.s soil in this regard a rare earth
processing plant has already been opened
in colorado but setting up a project of
this type takes time and this plant will
not begin to bear fruit until 2023 in
any case the important thing is that
everyone in the united
states is aware that we cannot continue
to depend on china and yes
they have also taken good note of the
japanese playbook
pentagon awards 30 million dollars in
rare earth funding to australia's linus
reuters surely now you can understand
why greenland has made so many headlines
in recent years
yes it is estimated that there are many
lanthanides there anyway at this point
the question is now over to you how do
you think western countries should act
to secure their supply of rare earth
elements
should they collaborate with china or
put up the money to challenge its
dominance but hang on a minute
while the chinese have rare earths the
western allies have something even more
important
control over the semiconductor industry
something that we already covered in the
past video about tsmc
taiwan and the chip war here on
visualpolitik don't miss it take care
we'll see you next time and if you want
to learn more about politics and hear
even more of my lovely voice
you can join us at reconsider media we
have a podcast at reconsider media.com
podcast see you there
[Music]